doing well I better sell I'm to change
nice to meet you hey Anderson welcome to
Johnson Western Center we're glad to
have you all I'm happy to be here man I
heard a lot about this place well I'm
glad you made it to Dallas I see you met
one of our local celebrities and brought
him along with you you're the biggest
live in the city
yeah
it's a big day for us to dodge the
question sugar we got two chains in
three commas yeah gotta give him some
exercise so the horse Jim mm it's a
treadmill it's about 40 grand the horse
Jim mm any clients the clients helps
with rehab would you have invested in
this a bit what it came your way
David is seeking $40,000 for 100% of
Equestrian Center
I'm not smart enough about horses but
seeing it it's a great idea tell me
about the Devils equestrianism
it's a huge facility where nine anchors
here in downtown Dallas okay we've got a
hundred and eighteen horses here we have
the lesson program does about two
hundred lessons a week how much are the
lessons lessons are a hundred dollars
apiece
most of the kids that are in our sport
they're gonna buy a horse or two and
they're gonna take at least three or
four lessons a week another piece I
can't even afford that then you have
horses here for sailors no will be
buying selling Lisi when you start out
you just want something safe your kids
can come ride have some fun or as you go
up in levels you're looking for more
performance than they jump better than
they moved better like this horse here's
$100,000 damn it's beautiful he's
actually not that pretty
[Music]
woman in California I think he's pretty
cuz I like it his Marcus he has white
socks on the opposite fear I've got like
a Versace look right hundred thousand is
kind of the entry level I mean you can
spend 250 500 a million a million
dollars on horse by happy birthday I
already know what I'm gonna hear with my
kids watch this episode I'm in trouble
[Music]
what's this horse man we gotta get my
name in aimin so when you talk about
getting $100,000 horse it's just a horse
correct that's just the board that does
include shipping and going to horse
shows and hotels and all the equipment
first we start off with a tack trunk we
put all the equipment in okay tank
technical stuff that's fancy so you put
all your stuff in here for all the
horses and everything you know you're
talking about saddles or you know four
to six thousand dollars for piece
brushes and all that and of course you
know they go cell phone chargers and all
that stuff for the kids
this whole chess is about 7,500 right
people fly their horses if you're going
more than four hours we'll fly the words
like we're gonna [ __ ] you fire them they
ship them FedEx I actually have them
they've actually converted some 727
symbol and actually got them out and
used for door-to-door hotels like so
layover barns and all the million
dollars you shipping from Europe for
Olympic teams and all that they're gonna
sit over for you to have passports for
horses actually I'm done aimin has a
passport a Manhattan passport
mm-hmm what else you got for me let's go
watch some horses jump around so this is
Squanto or hashtag a show horse here
this girl drives five days a week she'll
travel the country 3035 weeks a year
horse show and these are their personal
horses yeah so that's Eamon it was on
the treadmill earlier our friend Eamon
he good a woman he's good and warmed up
and ready to go and so what does a horse
show consist of like how do you lean so
there's judges they'll be judge in form
and function how well they jump how well
they execute the course
[Music]
it's like that was a mistake
so they'd count off on for that okay so
do you have to dress like that or cuz
someone come in just some cutoff jeans
in an event like attire like a question
attire correct correct
what's the total prize when you when you
get you a w-would is it like a big old
trophy like my man got when he won a
wouldn't you hear my ribbon a ribbon a
ribbon there's a million dollar Grom
fries and stuff like that problems you
can have to have a million dollar horse
to compete at that level well yeah
that's why that's right so this is the
last leader like you're not coming into
this sport thinking okay I'm I'm making
an investment of my kid and if they're
the best of the best
I'm gonna make my money back and then
some no this is the four-legged
boyfriend instead of the two-legged
boyfriend that no dad wants to put up
with Mark Cuban is out
[Music]